bonjour nouvelle édition du Journal de
la rédaction le 78 lactus sur TVfil 78
voici les titres en images de ce
vendredi 18 octobre la loi évolue en
matière d'égalité hommes-femm nous enfin
direment les militantes de elles aussi
l'association qui se bat depuis 1992
pour la parité en politique au municipal
de 2014 il y aura donc du changement
nous le verrons dans un instant
politique également avec dans cette
édition le modem l'UMP puis l'UDI qui
dévoileent leur candidats dans le
département après le PS la semaine
dernière quelques surprises à morpa ou
encore à véis et puis l'invité
aujourd'hui c'est Nicolas Hardy à la
tête d'une délégation de parents
d'élèves il demande le retrait immédiat
de la semaine de 4 jours et demi à
trrappe une manifestation vient d'avoir
lieu jeudi soir donc vous venez d'en
voir quelques images l'image du jour
justement c'est une photo Alain Delon et
sa fille réunie sur scène pour la pièce
une journée ordinaire mise en scène par
Jean-Luc Morau c'était un succès en 2011
au bouff parisien et ce devrait être
encore le cas ce vendredi soir à Montini
le bretonneur représentation à la Ferme
du Manet à 20h30 une journée ordinaire
qui retrace les difficultés de Julie 20
ans elle rêve de liberté d'émancipation
seulement elle vit seule avec son père
un homme une femme et entre les deux
beaucoup d'inégalités dans la société en
entreprise en politique aussi elles
aussi c'est une association qui milite
depuis 1980 12 pour cette parité elle a
décidé de rappeler que des progrès
avaient tout de même été réalisés et en
2014 les candidatures municipales vont
être fortement féminisé les explications
de yolen Torz et de Jonathan filman à
quelques mois des municipales le réseau
elsosi intensifie ses actions pour la
parité dans toutes les instances élues
d'autant plus que la loi du 17 avril
dernier modifiera complètement les
prochaines élections départemental un
homme et une femme vont se présenter en
même temps dans chaque canton autre
nouveauté dans le appartement des
Yvelines 60 communes de plus seront
concernées par les listes paritaires aux
prochaines élections municipales des
avancées réelles mais qui n'effaceent
pas certains stéréotypes elles ont quand
même besoin d'être boosté puisque
elles pensent on narrête pas de leur
faire des procès d'incompétence donc
elles pense qu'elles n'y arriveront
peut-être pas en plus il y a le problème
du partage ça vous le savez des tâches
domestiques où c'estes 80 % des tâches
sont faites par les femmes alors il est
bien évident à partir du moment où on
est élu qu'on a des responsabilités
qu'il faut qu'il faut un meilleur
partage des tâes donc faut réorganiser
faut réorganiser untit peu sa vie quand
même les 9 et 16 novembre deux forums
seront organisés dans le département
pour inciter les femmes à s'engager
actuellement sur les 262 communes on
compte moins de 60 femmes mères nous
avons des des élus actuels qui viendront
témoigner de la richesse de leur mandat
et devant des des personnes qui se
posent actuellement la question vais-je
me présenter dans quoi je m'embarque et
cetera est-ce que ça sera difficile
est-ce que je suis compétente est-ce que
les femmes se posent beaucoup de
questions une parité qui évolue donc
mais la présidente note quelques points
noirs à l'Assemblée nationale il y a que
26 % de femmes au Sénat il y a 22 % il y
a des progressions mais elles sont
lentes en France on compte actuellement
14 % de femmes
mères et justement imposer cette parité
homme-femme est-ce une bonne idée c'est
notre question du jour voici vos
réponses oh non je trouve ça inutile à
moi en fait à chacun chacun ses valeurs
et autant arriver à ces postes là par
son talent et par la conviction sans
pour cela imposer la parité bah c'est
normal faut nous représenter quand même
je sais pas bien sûr alors pourquoi bah
moi-même nous avons deux filles et ça me
semble tout à fait évident qu'elle soit
considérée de la même façon que des
hommes et la parité c'est bien dans son
esprit parce que c'est vrai que il faut
donner la chance aux femmes autant
qu'aux hommes d'apparaître sur le au
public et de se révéler dans des
positions politiques ou autres mais s'il
y a moins de femmes que d'hommes qui
peuvent s'engager et qui ont le temps de
s'engager parce que les femmes elles ont
autre chose à faire bon
euh pourquoi
pas politique toujours le modem des
ivelines en ordre de marche pour les
municipales 38 candidats désignés ils
seront soit tête de liste soit présents
sur des listes de rassemblement des
listes d'union le détail sur notre
secteur avec Catherine zulato et
Jonathan
filman le modem en ordre de marche dans
le département 38 candidats sont pour
l'instant connus soit ils seront tête de
liste soit les électeurs pourront les
retrouver sur des listes d'union on est
positionné à peu près partout dans les
villes de plus de 10 1500 habitants on
aura des candidats partout notre
ambition en fait c'est déjà de soutenir
des projets locaux d'avoir des élus pour
2014 c'est important on a les interc qui
se mettent en place il faut qu'on soit
représenter dans les conseils
communautaires euh les élections
sénatoriales qui approchent mais dans un
futur un peu un peu plus lointain et euh
il faut qu'on soit très très près
présent en terme de représentation dans
les ivelines sur notre secteur certains
emmèneront une liste modème c'est le cas
de Jean-Luc Aria à guilloncour il avait
déjà présenté une liste aux dernières
élections municipales on a un projet
assez
structuré sur lequel on veut se battre
pour changer Guy encour pour être en
mouvement à Guy encour parce qu'il nous
semble queon est dans les mêmes schémas
depuis trop longtemps il y a de plus en
plus de gens qui s'aperçoivent que Guy
en cour est une ville très séparée sur
lequel il faut mettre du Lian de la
démocratie locale Jean-Lou Arya devra
batailler contre un ancien modem Julien
auchochel dans l'opposition municipale
il a décidé de se rapprocher du maire
sortant le socialiste François de Ligier
c'est un choix personnel qu'il a fait
que nous regrettons
mais il a fait ce choix de quitter le
modem et de quitter donc notre travail
c'est un choix
personnel les autres villes de notre
secteur les candidats modem feront
listes communes avec des formations
assez diverses PS Europe Écologie Les
ver ou encore UMP c'est le cas de Benoît
Cordin à trappe on le retrouvera sur la
liste
d'otmanastro c'est une ville qui est
absolument passionnante par sa diversité
aussi bien ethnique que culturelle que
sociale et un moment donné c'est une
ville dans laquelle on a envie de faire
des choses depuis maintenant plus d'un
demi-sècle c'est une ville qui est gérée
par la gauche qui est gérée de façon
totalement électoraliste pour seule
vocation de gagner les élections année
après année certains font le choix de
rallier les mères sortant UMP c'est le
cas à Versailles on a fait un énorme
travail sur le terrain de sur Versailles
vous avez pu énormément de réalisation
dont on est extrêmement fier et je pense
que le MoDem a eu vraiment sa part sur
François nous a vraiment donné sa
confiance il y a aucune raison qu'on
reparte pas avec lui même cas de figure
à voisin le Bretonneux malgré la
candidature d'une élu udi Alexandra
Rosetti Elisabethe de Viterne Biet su
puis logiquement le maire actuel c'est
normal qu'on puisse continuer à
travailler ensemble sur les projets dans
une commune qui ne sont jamais
complètement abouti d'un mandat au bout
d'un mandat donc qui se prolonge sur
d'autres mandats et voilà ça me paraît
c'est normal de continuer à hencour
Laurent verra est en pleine discussion
avec Dominique clochon ancien élu sur la
liste du maire sortant Jean-Michel
Fourgous il va falloir discuter
des cœur du programme dans les dans les
semaines et les mois à venir à titre
personnel j'aimerais bien qu'une chose
soit mise en avant c'est le c'est un
programme pour le cœur de ville sur
encour parce que je considère que c'est
une ville qui manque de qui manque de
dont le cœur fait défauts amort pas
George béief envisage une liste avec le
groupe modem des élections de 2008 à
saintc l'école Éveline duquois travaille
elle aussi sur une liste indépendante on
va travailler pour proposer un autre
projet citoyen de manière à ce que que
la vie sur sa-ire soit plus respectueuse
et il fasse bon VI parce qu'on a
l'impression que la ville commence à
devenir ville d'ortoire où il n'y a plus
de commerce où il n'y a plus
d'association il'y a plus de vie et là
je voudrais faire revivre ma ville voilà
les modems seront donc un peu partout
avec des thématiques communes la
démocratie locale la maîtrise des
dépenses et le développement durable le
parti de François berou compte environ
600 adhérents dans le
département à mon repa la situation à
droite s'éclaircit l'UMP département a
donné son investiture à grégoryi
garestier responsable de la section
locale qui siège au conseil municipal de
cette ville depuis la fin du mois de
septembre on écoute sa réaction à
l'issue de cette décision de
l'UMP je suis très heureux que ma
famille politique à laquelle
j'appartiens depuis depuis sa création m
fait confiance pour cette élection
municipale et pour la la représenter en
tant que tête de liste euh c'est le
choix de la cohérence
c'est le choix du Mérite de la confiance
et puis c'est le choix du renouvellement
voilà je pense que ma famille politique
a aussi misé sur le renouvellement
vraiment des générations à morpas dont
on avait tant besoin pour préparer
l'alternance ma légitimité voilà est
reconnue officiellement par mes pères et
j'en suis très heureux et je remercie
également tous mes soutiens je remercie
surtout mon député jean-féric
poisson garestier qui a justement reçu
l'investiture du Parti chrétien
déémocrate de Jean-Frédéric Poisson le
député de la 10e circonscription l'UMP
des Yvelines l'a donc préféré en tout
cas à Pierre Le guuerinel l'ancien
Premier Adjoint udi du maire sortant
George Mougeot Pierre Le guuerinel qui
avait pourtant le soutien de Valérie
pcrè la patronne de l'UMP départemental
il se dit surpris et ne pas comprendre
ce choix contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer c'est pas de la
déception ni de l'amertume mais c'est de
la surprise parce que je suis toujours
surpris que euh en politique on Fe pas
les bon
calcul je suis surpris parce que jouer
la carte du chacun il va seul au premier
tour bon après tout c'est légitime mais
ça empêche de créer une dynamique forte
et ça c'est un peu gant d'utant que ce
que j'imagine pas mais en mettant les
choses au pire si ça doit conduire par
exemple à perdre la ville c'est un très
mauvais calcul pour l'UMP parce que ça
fait dans le même temps les voies des
grands électeurs dont certains auront
besoin pour les
sénatoriales ça obère une partie de ce
que l'UMP se raeler la reconquête et la
Transformer donc je suis un peu surpris
qu'il n'it pas réalisé à quel point il
prenait un risque pierre leerinel qui
maintiendra donc sa candidature avec
l'étiquette de son parti l'UDI justement
qui a répondu à cette situation par la
voix de son par la voix de son
responsable le député Arnaud Richard
pardon responsable départemental de la
formation udi il annonce avoir mandaté
trois de ses membres pour renouer le
dialogue et conforter l'union avec l'UMP
et puisqu'il est question des municipal
les choses s'accélèrent aussi à
saint-cire l'école après la candidature
du ma sortant Bernard Debin investi par
l'UMP Daniel Gerson di ver gauche
annonce sa candidature avec le soutien
du parti socialiste s'ajoute aussi la
candidature d'Étienne herassimus divers
droite nous partons pour la verrière non
pas pour parler des municipales mais
parce que le maire a été reçu à Matignon
cette semaine un entretien avec
Jean-Marc hraud qui fait suite à un
courrier qu'il lui avait adressé au
lendemain des événements estivaux qui
ont agité la ville de trappe mais aussi
celle de la verrière Alain agage demandé
au gouvernement un choc de dignité il
demandait aussi des mesures des actions
d'envergure pour les quartiers
populaires Jean-Marc herud qui pourrait
d'ailleurs venir à La Verrière dans les
prochaines semaines je lui ai dit
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple pour tout un
ensemble de de personnes qui ont envie
de réussir envie de porter des projets
que ça soit professionnel personnel
collectif ou individuel c'était
quelquefois la croix et la bannière que
les démarches étaient lourdes longues et
que l'échelle temps était pas la même
entre les attentes urgentes des
habitants et et le temps des
administrations et donc il fallait
absolument déconcentrer décentraliser
des aides je lui ai dit que moi j'étais
favorable à un guichet unique des
services publics dans les quartiers de
manière à ce que tous ceux qui
travaillent pour l'accompagnement des
habitants que ce soit sur le point de
vue social ou professionnel ou de
formation que les habitants n'ai pas ne
soient pas obligés de faire des
démarches dans toute l'agglomération
nouvelle pour ici remplir un dossier CAF
ici avoir une aide à l'aide à
l'entreprise ici déposer un CV au Pôle
Emploi ici se renseigner sur des droits
aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement compliqué
je l'avais dit extrêmement humiliant
d'être sans arrêt obligé de prouver ce
que l'on veut d'où on est et les
difficultés qu'on rencontre donc dans
nos quartiers on doit être capable je
lui ai dit que j'étais disponible avec
la maison de quartier du Bois de l'étan
par exemple pour la transformer en en
une maison des services publics et du
Citoyen où à la fois on est un guichet
unique pour accompagner les habitants et
à la fois on est une espèce
de de lieu central de la citoyenneté la
verrière se propose d'être un
laboratoire s'il le faut d'idées
nouvelles pour le bien des habitants le
maire de la verrière qui espère que ses
idées seront retenues dans le cadre du
projet de loi sur la ville sur lequelle
travaille en ce moment le ministre
François lamis projet qui pourrait être
dévoilé avant la fin de cette année
l'invité de cette édition je reçois
Nicolas hardi bonjour bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes le président de
l'association des parents d'élèves
indépendants de Trapp hier soir vous
avez manifesté devant le hôtel de ville
pour demander le retrait immédiat de la
semaine de 4 jours et demi on va en voir
justement quelques images les parents
qui se mobilisent qui demandent le
retrait de cette réforme des rythmes
scolaires comment s'est passé cette
mobilisation est-ce que vous avez été
reçu également en mairie alors la mob
bon je je regrette que la mobilisation
était faible bon on a eu une vingtaine
de personnes qui se sont qui se sont
déplacé ça se'est déroulé aux alentours
de 17h 17h donc effectivement c'est
encore c'est encore un peu tôt pour
gmobiliser les parents euh parallèlement
donc moi effectivement j'étais j'étais
présent lors d'un comité de pilotage en
ville donc avec les élus le représentant
du préfet représentant de la CAF les l'a
pour traiter justement de cette question
là fa pour mettre en place pour mettre
en place le Pdt donc le projet éducatif
territorial qui devrait effectivement
permettre permettre un nouveau
plutôt une meilleure disposition
proposition des des rythmes d'accord
c'est pour affiner encore ce qui ce qui
a été mis en place est-ce que vous
pensez vraiment pour pouvoir obtenir ce
retour en arrière parce que la mairie
s'est engagée la réforme doit passer en
2014 ce sont les autres communes qui
n'ont pas encore franchi le pas qui vont
devoir le faire et vous pensez que là
attrape on peut retirer pour les après
les vacances de la toussin cette ce
rythme à 4 4 jours et demi si j'étais
persuadé du contraire enfin que je
pourrais pas le faire j'arrêterai là
voilà effectivement il y a je pense que
maintenant il y a un bras de fer qui
s'est engagé entre la ville et et les
parents d'élèves il est clair que en en
entendant les propos de de la ville euh
enfin de de ces élus effectivement tout
va bien voilà justement qu'est-ce que
vous reprochez à cette réforme c'est
c'est c'est qu qure jours et demi de
classe fonctionne pas ce ce qu' ce qui
ne fonctionne pas excusez-moi euh déjà
premièrement des des enfants fatigué euh
fatigué énervé et ça le rencontre dès le
jeudi vous avez les enseignants aussi
vous le dises est-ce que vous avez des
témoignagenseignant on fait on fait un
travail de de prospection sur toute la
ville he par des questionnaires par des
pétitions enfin tous les les les les
parents sont sont mobilisés sur la
question les enseignants le font de leur
côté aussi donc effectivement on a des
on a aussi des retours quand vous avez
des des des des élèves en en CM1 CM2 qui
en le jeudi après-midi s'endorment en
classe on peut que constater une
saturation pour l'élève vous parlez
aussi de dysfonctionnement dans la mise
en place et la qualité des TAP ce sont
les temps d'activité péri éducatif alors
des des des des dysfonctionnements
effectivement on a des des ateliers
alors effectivement la programmation je
je critiquerai pas pas la programmation
telle qu'elle nous est proposée euh ça
serait un petit peu mal habile et
maladroit de ma part mais effectivement
des des activités qui sont proposées
comme le théâtre je prends un exemple où
effectivement ben dès qu'il y a un
manque en plus voilà on constate des
manques d'animateur effectivement B le
les activités sont des fois remplacées
par du simple coloriage alors je pense
pas que les parents je me semble pas que
les parents aent inscrit leurs enfants
dans cette optique euh de plus pour
revenir aux animateurs il soit ils sont
en nombre
insuffisant soit quelques-uns je je ne
parlerai pas pour tous les animateurs
mais soit que certains certains sont mal
formé ou pas formé contrairement à ce
que Monsieur Malandin nous affirmaé le
31 janvier 2013 trappe pour pour
repréciser pour ceux qui n'habiteraient
pas la commune justement par rapport à
ces animateurs vous avez des vraies
critiques contre eux parce que pour
certains vous parlez d'agissement
d'animateur envers les enfants qui ne
seraiit pas appropriés alors
effectivement on a on a des retours on a
des retours donc monsieur monsieur
Malandin hier faisait encore part que
c'était que
des desd des parents excusez-moi quand
effectivement disant que les parents
n'ont pas vu mais j'aiess moi
personnellement effectivement je n'ai
pas vu mais de quelle mais j'ai entendu
que ça soit dans dans les propos verbaux
que ça soit dans dans dans dans des dans
des gestes dans des attitudes gestuel
donc donc je pas non plus je va pas
faire le procès des
animateursant ens tout à fait on on
l'affirme et et la ville se cachant
derrière son mutisme dans cette affaire
nous nous saisirons le tribunal
administratif la réforme se met en place
trapper l'une des premières villes c'est
d'ailleurs l'une des des dizaines de
communes dans le département qui qui a
tenté de mettre en place la réforme et
qui met en place la réforme dès cette
année il faut pas faire preuve de
patience
aussi la la la patience moi je veux bien
mais si on a des élèves qui en fin de
semaine sont avant la fin de semaine
sont déjà or circuit c'est pas un
nouveau projet que vous demandez ce que
vous demandez c'est l'annulation
complète de cette réformme demand je
demande le le enfin nous demandons la
remise dès la rentrée de la toussin au
la semaine des 4 jours et de travailler
sur un réel projet on a 8 mois devant
nous
même un peu plus un réel projet pour la
rentrée 2014 ce qui aurait dû être fait
dès le début voilà et hier
soir un intervenant a rappelé que
Monsieur héros effectivement disait
qu'il fallait du temps hm hm et Fall
temp donc effectivement première
abration et là c'est du gouvernement ne
pas de pas proposer un choix mais
effectivement appliquer cette réforme en
2014 pour tout le monde en 2014 pour
tout le monde et si la demi-journée
supplémentaire choisie était le samedi
est-ce que ça serait mieux ça
simplifierait les choses aussi ça
permettrait un temps de pause le
mercredi Moci c'est que moi
personnellement j'étais favorable au
mercredi donc je ve pas je veux pas le
cacher euh vous pouvez aussi dire que
maintenant peut c'est que je vois je
vois également comme j'ai dit hier soir
les les personnes peut-être les plus
aptes à évaluer les enfants c'est quand
même les parents et nous on constate
effectivement d jeudi vendredi une
fatigue et un énervement des enfants
donc vous dit pas aujourd'hui vous ne
dites pas non au samedi hein je ne dis
pas non au samedi pour réfléchir alors
effectivement ça là c'est ma c'est la
quand je dis non quand je dis oui au
samedi c'est ma position personnelle et
ce n'est pas ma position enfin je parler
c'est pas la position de l'enemb du du
groupe on l'a bien entendu une toute
dernière question est-ce que c'est un
enjeu de campagne il y a des élections
municipales tout de même en mars on sent
à chacune de de vos sorties aussi on le
voit il des opposants au maire pour ne
pas citer Hotman massrou par exemple qui
est soutenu par l'UMP qui a chacune de
de chacun de vos communiqués lui aussi
fait part d'un communiqué explique qu'il
est contre cette réforme est-ce qu'il y
a des liens entre vous est-ce qu'il y a
des échanges po pas liens moi j'ai j'ai
rencontré j'ai rencontré
euh des des personnes du PC j'ai
rencontré j'ai rencontré également
monsieur naserou euh c'est pas une
revendication polique auourd je lui ai
mis je lui ai mis également quelques
critiques moi personnellement
effectivement monsieur enfin l'équipe
municipale t a faire croire que je joue
un un jeu politique euh donc je vais
sortir de mon contexte mais
effectivement je suis déjà passé ici sur
ce plateau pour des questions politique
au jour d'aujourd'hui j'ai j'ai je ne
suis plus encarté nulle part euh les
statut de les statut de l'UNAP enfin de
notre associationès cl c ma question il
y a pas de question politique derre et
du des statuts nationaux m'empêche
d'avoir des activités politiques en tant
que membre d'administration nationale
même président de l'association donc on
vous retoua pas sur une liste en mars
prochain très clair colardi d'être venu
sur ce plateau je rappelle cette
manifestation hier et puis votre demande
de retirer cette réforme de 4 jours et
demi afin de refaire un bilan avant de
présenter un nouveau projet pour 2014
merci à vous une autre manifestation des
élèves du lycéemilie Breteuil à Montini
du lycée Mansar à saint-sier l'école uni
également pour une même cause le soutien
à leonarda une jeune licène de 15 ans
arrêtée lors d'une sortie scolaire
expulsée au Kosovo et malgré les zones
d'ombre qui entourent ce dossier l'UNEF
le syndicat étudiant veut en faire un
exemple des centaines de lycéens dans la
rue à 50 ans en Yveline ce vendredi
matin des jeunes du lycée é mililie de
Breteuil de Montini le Bretonneux
rejoint par d'autres du lycée Mansard de
saint-ciier l'école une voix lycéenne
qui voulait largement se faire entendre
en soutien à leonarda 15 ans arrêté lors
d'une sortie scolaire et expulsé au
Kosovo c'est le triste exemple d'une
politique migratoire tout simplement
inhumaine et à l'encontre des valeurs de
de l'école de la République le lycée le
lycée dans lequel nous on apprend tous
les jours c'est lycée de la République
il est pour tout le monde la
manifestation était encadrée par l'UNEF
et malgré les ombres qui entourent le
dossier de cette famille les révélations
du père qui avoue avoir menti sur ses
origines le syndicat étudiant souhaite
faire de ce dossier un exemple quand on
est dans une situation de précarité moi
je m'en fous qu'on mente il faut juste
se mettre à sa place le mec qui vient
quand même du Kosovo territoire qui a
été en guerre DEP pendant de nombreuses
années donc moi je peux comprendre qui
pour avoir des papiers il passe par des
stratagèmes divers et la deuxième chose
c'est qu'on est pas ici seulement ici
aujourd'hui pour leonarda on est ici
pour toutes les lycéens lycéenes et
collégiennes qui sonont expulsés chaque
année c'est cinq lycéens en moyenne qui
sont expul ses parents et ça c'est une
situation qu'on peut plus accepter une
enquête administrative est en cours les
conclusions devraient être bientôt
connues prévention routière entre
accidents des de roues en hausse
réflexion autour de la réduction de la
vitesse et pas uniquement ville le
préfet des Yvelines s'est exprimé il
évoque des actions de prévention à
mettre en place euh on doit y travailler
on doit essayer de faire prendre
conscience aux motocyclistes que leur
comportement est parfois dangereux bien
sûr il y a toujours ou le plus souvent
une un véhicule qui un autre véhicule
qui est engagé dans ces accidents
néanmoins c'est souvent le comportement
du motocycliste qui qui qui cause qui
cause le danger par ailleurs il y a la
situation des trois roues des secouteurs
à trois roues où là il y a on constate
des défauts de maîtrise de ces engins
par leur propriétaire il n'est pas
impossible que nous envisagions à titre
expérimental et pédagogique des
opérations sur la route pour essayer de
faire prendre conscience aux
motocyclistes que le fait de de doubler
les véhicules sur la file de droite peut
présenter un danger donc nous allons
faire ça dans les jours et les semaines
qui viennent à Montini le breteneux
l'enseigne Bricorama va disparaître la
direction indique être victime de la
concurrence de l'enseigne ler roi Merlin
le dimanche est situé sur le même
secteur à boisarsy notamment une
autorisation dominicale dont ce magasin
de centreville ne disposait en revanche
pas M Bricorama Montini le Bretonneux
perdait 100000 € par mois selon le
président du groupe une voilà une
nouvelle qui interviendra une fermeture
qui interviendra ici la fin de cette
année une librairie s'inquiète également
de son avenir toujours à Montini le
Bretonneux après ce magasin qui va
fermer de bricolage che la librairie le
pavé du canal qui pourrait aussi fermer
installé depuis 24 ans à Montini le
Bretonneux elle subit la concurrence des
ventes en ligne le développement des
livre numérique encore le prix des
loyers trop élevé en centr-eville son
fondateur souhaite passer la main pour
l'instant les repreneurs ne se
bousculent pas quelques mot de santé
pour poursuivre ce journal dans le cadre
de la Semaine du mal du dos les
chiropracteur offre jusqu'à ce vendredi
dis soir des consultations gratuites
pour vous permettre de faire un bilan
dorsal 8 Français sur 10 ont mal au dos
au moins une fois par an le mal de dos
et la cause de 13 % des arrêts maladies
et il coûte au moins 1 milliard d'euros
chaque année à la Caisse Primaire
d'Assurance Maladie la caisse primaire
justement d'assurance maladie dans les
ivelines a participé activement à la
journée du don de jeudi en organisant
ici à Versailles un village du don où il
était possible d'en savoir plus sur les
associations qui nous sollicitent tout
au long de l'année don de soi don du
sang de plaquette le don sous toutes ses
formes il était bien évidemment possible
de s'engager sur place de passer de la
parole aux actes on écoute le directeur
adjoint de la CPM au micro
d'éod euh la caisse primaire souhaite
depuis maintenant plusieurs années
s'engager dans une démarche sociale et
responsable avec ses salariés et la
caisse primaire est un acteur de la
santé important dans les gibelines et
aujourd'hui on trouvait que c'était euh
bien d'avoir cette journée comme point
d'org euh pour pour marquer cette
journée du don on attend tout simplement
que de mobiliser nos collaborateurs mais
aussi le public qui vient euh qui vient
nous rendre visite dans nos locaux
l'opération phare de la journée du don
c'est le don du sang en partenariat avec
l'établissement français du sang ce don
du sang était ouvert à l'ensemble du
personnel de la caisse primaire des
gblines et aujourd'hui on on aura plus
de 70 donneurs sur la
journée la semaine du handicap s
terminée au Pierre de Coubertin avec le
triathlon de l'espérance organisé par
l'association métier handicap fondé par
Sébastien pryard chaque année le même
principe des vedette viennent relever
trois défis c'est le chanteur Grégoire
qui s'est prêté au jeu du basket
fauteuil l'occasion de découvrir de
façon ludique le monde du handicap
d'approcher le vécu des personnes en
situation de handicap autre marine de
cette édition 2013 vous l'avez aperçu
c'est Lucienne Morau son visage ne vous
est pas inconnu vous avez pu l' voir sur
Canal Plus et elle avait un message en
direction de cette association méia
handicap
méia handicap ensemble sur la même ligne
à
départ message de Lucienne pour terminer
cette édition du vendredi du 78 lactu je
vous retrouve lundi en direct 18h
excellent
weekend